hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the Blair Witch game now
you've probably heard of it if you
haven't even seen the movie you've
probably at least heard of the Blair
Witch Project a very influential if not
the most well shot horror movie in the
world but that's because it has this
very specific style that they call
found-footage it's kind of the same as
the game outlast in a lot of other
horror movies that are about people
finding footage that other people have
filmed when those other people have
probably died and that's what this game
is about so let's get into this and I
should also mention that this is a
pre-release version of the game so it
should be close to what the release
version to be but if there are bugs or
anything like that just be a little
forgiving and hopefully everything will
be butter I don't know who a Bluebird
team is what I hope they do horror well
I mean it looks good I mean this is just
a cinematic but if it's any reflection
of the game it's kind of similar to the
Resident Evil 2 remake intro
oh you could do Poochie
you know you should probably be pulling
over for the police I think that's kind
of the law well I got the sirens on you
got to pull over whatever it's okay not
like they're trying to get you I mean
just pull over to the side of the roads
to get other way anyway I want to be
driving you take care okay tap middle or
tab to get your phone Jess first answer
to answer all right whatever you hear
about the missing kid you're joining the
search why wouldn't it be you know why
never mind all right
maybe I should've called no just wait
wait wait
I'm almost there oh I'll call you later
okay all right well the only reasons
that it would be a bad idea is because
of my extensive history of kidnapping
kids oh maybe I had a kid that went
missing in the woods and then couldn't
find it
maybe that's what it's about you know
honestly it's funny because the actual
movie was so weird that I never really
understood why you were in the woods in
the first place I never understood what
they were trying to do but then again
it's been so long since I saw the movie
I know they were just like oh witch in
the woods and we got to film it but I
never really understood what the witch
could do or why it could do the things
that it did like the heart in the and
the little napkin why I didn't get that
why was he standing in the corner at the
end why was he a naughty timeout of the
end I don't know what did this witch
make you do but either way I'm a sucker
for a good setting where you go into a
haunted forest see if we can find a way
to contact sheriff Lanny oh this game
started without its hundred percent love
it all right let's find this kid he's
been through enough already okay Anthony
if you stopped pining your pond what
every time someone mentions the witch
and decided to show up check the trunk
there's a walkie-talkie in there for you
I'm also leaving you a photo the kid
we're looking for call sheriff landing
on channel 2 once you're ready to join
us okay cool hey sheriff landing
I'm here with bullet that's my dog's
name I'm a dog don't pay anything for
you I'll protect you to the end of my
days and if this game does anything
horrible to you
I will go studio and I will personally
punch every single person who made that
happen please don't let anything bad
happen to you
I would die for you a million times over
pooch I would do it I would I would hey
what's this huh good morning diaries
it's proven wrong buddy prove all wrong
man you read fast land and call for you
at the station from the mayor something
about the press conference I said I'd
pass a message call him back PS I heard
Ellis is taking interest in the search
just say no I know you two have a
history but he's damaged goods as far as
I'm concerned am i Ellis I'm Ellis right
okay well
Oh dogs neck leather wallet what's in my
wallet
hey hey looking good so she hasn't aged
a day since then that's so weird when
you look at oh hey what's this sorry
your fortune something of value is lost
fear not for I see that there is still a
chance to recover it though your time is
running thin you must act now venture
forth without fear as Lady Luck smiles
upon those brave of heart place trust in
your friends as they will come to your
aid when most needed my advice watch
your step your lucky numbers 2 and 125
I bet this all pertains to something I
bet this fortune is for real normally
you would throw away fortunes at the
wiliest Nili and not pay attention to
him but I will read into this and I will
go and I don't know what my history my
trip to Santa Monica
but you guys mind if I just break into
all of your cars especially the police
cars
the officer was notified of the
disappearance of Peter Shannon by his
mother Laura Shannon the initial
investigating officer we established
following Peter was last seen heading to
his friend's house around 11:20 a.m. on
September 15th 1996 mr. Chanin was been
unavailable to locate him ever since
what's up boy I'm right in here Peter
I read in here Peter has a history of
previous attempts to run away from home
there no one knows thanks for you there
are no y witnesses of the moments Peters
disappearance 15:30 the initial search
yielded no results to the Shannons age
the risk of imminent recess is high in
order to organized a search in the Black
Hills force where the boy was found
during one of his previous escapes was
given sheriff Emmitt landing has been
appointed with head the operation signed
officer Mathewson investing officer
well it oh we're not leaving that laying
around what right boy bully you care
about the environment
hello ah this some form of a dildo or
possibly a very bad spear
maybe both I have no idea I'll take it
though I'll put it in my pocket better
not rush into this need to find a way to
contact a search party what excuse me I
rush into everything I do blind we do
Arcadius interesting why was that an
achievement cellphone games Cobra
masters I love this game oh yeah oh yeah
here we go
greatest game ever great greatest game
oh sorry Anthony first come first oh
okay that's all I needed okay I'm an
idiot I was wandering around here for a
little bit into the woods then here I go
for me here we go let's do this hey oh
that's reassuring sound the weirdly
sharp gate that doesn't seem to work
very well come on let's go find this kid
yeah let's go find this kid definitely
gonna work out well for me
[Music]
okay interesting
that's a bit of a problem that's that's
fish that's what you call one of those
problems that's that's not good that's
what you call not good the Blair wheels
okay
ah good and never returning stone jump
always love those sure love the fact
that I could never come back if I want
to no point waiting any longer
it's called landing all right let's call
landing all right let's do it I'll do it
then Channel two hell it's the base she
copy hello oh you know a search party
sir here to help
it's all there is to it well it's with
me if he catches the scent he'll lead us
straight to the kid yeah I'm not gonna
screw this up not this time Roger that
over now okay all right and thank you
for like violating HIPAA and talking
about my health issues over an unsecured
radio frequency bullet come here who's a
good boy it was a good boy good boy this
bullet your right-hand dog listen to his
barking watch his body language he'll be
the first to alarm you of any trouble
but it'll need to help deal with it
remember the way you treat him can
affect his behavior later in the game
stay close to him for long loneliness
can affect your mental state if you lose
sight a bullet press C to call him back
when he's nearby looking them and hold C
to command toggle wheel seek pets
Nicholas Day and reprimand I would never
I would never
we'd never bullet would go get come on
bullet go
hey we're looking for Peter not the
search party buddy oh you're a good boy
though you're a good boy you're a good
boy oh the best game best game ever best
game 10/10 let's find something buddy oh
boy oh boy
you okay possessed they're close to me
[Music]
[Applause]
might have been a raccoon well you could
say I'd call Oh can't believe I have to
cross I got your message yeah not much
luck so far
but hey yeah at least bullets after
we're out of the house and Jess I'm
sorry about earlier
[Applause]
[Applause]
stick close to me apparently not
can I get some tongue can't think about
things cannot think about things about
allowed to think okay so you talking
about that place that place so what's up
what you see boy which is it whoa good
boy good boy
this is what you brought this sock I'm
fine why did I keep that why did I keep
this sock boy whoa that's very clearly
something out of the ordinary here I'm
not I don't know there's a teddy bear up
against a tree and nothing to say about
it
all right bullet we're gonna keep moving
just watch out for anything I don't know
what part of the world we're in but by
some big scary animals around here
somewhere
it's pretty I'll give it that it's very
oh that good good find and the world's
not your goddamn trash can
yeah get out here my wrist there's
something wrong with my wrist okay don't
think that with me put it in my junk
drawer maybe I'll pick up the pace maybe
I'll start running I was enjoying a nice
walk away actually where did we Circle
did waitress did we just come back away
macam I did didn't I I did I did I
really did didn't I I just went in a
gosh-darn circle didn't I I bet there's
gonna be that same piece of trash that's
just up the way up here right up here ah
okay so I'm an idiot and I
went the wrong way okay that's good I
guess I'll be back guys when I'm not
stupid so I guess I might never actually
come back but I you know that actually
is an interesting point because that
says how easy it is to get turned around
in the forest because I was just
following the trail and I ended up just
in a big circle who's to say a kid
wandering around couldn't get lost like
that when I was a kid you know go in the
woods all the time and even if I was
following the creek sometimes I'd get
turned around cuz it all looks the same
but I've got an impeccable sense of
direction so I don't think I'm gonna get
ported by this in any way shape or form
even though I'm clearly walking in a
circle again oh ha ha ho bring it to me
boy bring it to me boy well I bring it
to me ooh
ok cave found something hey come on boy
fine good boy good boy good boy
you know that's what I was not the time
your food you're acting a little Stifler
quick rose that's Peters cap yeah boy
good boy good boy can you follow the
scent come on buddy sniff sniff sniff
deep sniff strong fine this said take me
to a boy base found Peters cat I'm not
risking him losing it
I'll keep you posted over now ok yeah
yeah let's just go off on our own then
yeah this is gonna go good ok boy yeah I
trust you ok yeah good good a good move
good move boys thanks boys thank you
thank you bullet for that oh the woods
turned a lot weird that's bizarre damn
it
ah
Boland bullet the blue blood boy follow
my whistle bullet who's a good boy my
boy any day now come on buddy
Oh Anne what's what we're off at the
hell is he what
what happened to the woods was David no
not now not now what no now what whoa
what's happening boys get a grip Alice
not giving up now all right
what happening to me well what's
happening to me I have no idea what's
happening are you calm down Alice
hey stop sniffing me oh well there we go
okay here I go yep fallen over now great
maybe I should have bowling oh god I
thought that wasn't bullet for a second
there how cruel would it have been if
the game was like this is bullet well
it's gonna be your constant companion to
show up now it would have been the
leaving I just can't be alone everybody
it wouldn't you find something it would
have been such a story be if they set up
all this like bull it's gonna be your
companion you need to behave be nice to
bullet or bullets behavior will be
affected by the time you get like out of
there and what if bullet was just taken
away right at the beginning of the game
so you're like oh cuz I had an instant
bond with bullet if you got boy boy
where you got what do you got boy okay
alright this is y'all stop leading me
through brush okay oh yeah yeah yeah
let's uh hey hey hey hey Jess no it's
fine it's under control no I said I'm
fine I'm fine
listen I think I saw something I got to
go
I'll call you later
I'm sorry Jess when I wonder what this
guy's deal is maybe some kind of PTSD it
did say that he was used to be in the
army and he seems to be a very ill
otário oriented type person just judging
by the way he responds to radio calls oh
yeah yeah bullet this looks good yeah
but this looks real good bullet this
looks real good you know maybe we
shouldn't be in the middle of the woods
bullets I'm sorry
what's with the singing in the wool
Jenna camps a funky look but yeah you're
right Oh
footage time still works
oh boy yes
oh hell yeah Oh give me the good stuff
oh yes zoom in on that oh yeah
completely ignore my surroundings for
the sake of whatever that's going on in
that
oh yeah it's a great idea oh it's good
Alice maybe you should no I'm fine I'll
deal with it I just need a little more
time unless what you need is help
because I managed Ellis I can't do this
anymore what what is it this time what I
wasn't smiling enough didn't say I love
you for five [ __ ] minutes Jesus
Christ
Ellis do you even hear yourself yeah I
could hear myself just fine and I can
see the way you look at me like I'm a
[ __ ] loser you know sick little puppy
for you to look after man for once oh
yeah there it is there it is
[Music]
I hope you can figure it out nice oh you
finally forgive yourself I tried to help
you but
I just can't be around you anymore go
ahead get out leave me the [ __ ] alone
[Music]
be a man
[Music]
cheaper better yeah I want to introduce
you to someone
bullet meet your new partner he's been
through a lot just like you what sir I
can't well you got something else going
on right now just take the damn dog
Ellis yeah yes sir what all right hello
okay did I pass out oh no some movie I
just watched boy that weirdly contained
a lot of personal memories oh yeah this
is good
oh this is good hello oh we have here
listen again unless I wanted too much
time with my answer uh-huh yeah okay
someone definitely too much time there's
definitely not a word
oh hey yeah that thing again good good
job bullet yeah I'll look at it now how
did it end up back here oh I don't know
it's almost like I never had it in the
first place there's a tape inside might
as well see what's on it
Matt is really with Sonny so the red
tapes allow you to minute the red tails
allow your manipulate reality Vantage
for the environment and objects rules
around you and in the video fast forward
rewind and stop the video and the chemos
to change their states and position oh I
don't know dad
I'm sorry this wasn't here a minute ago
get it together it's probably Peters
maybe both could catch a scent hi bud hi
bulk up stiffness bullet comes does step
is a grool gonna eat that boy you do
great on the force if you want stubborn
some leftovers inside maybe a few days
old hey whoa whoa bullet okay I'm coming
bowling I'm coming okay I don't know
what you're showing me bullet but I'm on
the way do I look different I feel
different
it's been about two hours since I was
literally just playing but for you time
has not been standing still hi
anyway back into the woods where was I I
just found a toy truck car a police car
toy police car weights point wrong what
is it yeah oh I see okay
destroy
I didn't do anything
what Oh God okay I didn't do anything I
didn't click anything I didn't I didn't
mean to destroy it but there I did I
sure did destroy it good that you can
see well it scholar even in the darkness
shit's a good boy you're such a good boy
even though we're in the dark and
everything is horrifying you're still
good boy stick close to me stick close
to me bullet it's dangerous around here
you don't want to go running off you
never know what's lurking in the
darkness okay yeah unreturnable Joe good
great unless I can climb which is
probably not something I can do I don't
think seem to be the most physically
capable I should check what this is
about
yeah no I should check we went down a
ravine and headed north to an old
campsite no you didn't find Peters cap
either listen we're still on the trail
we'll keep moving north okay
just find the campsite and head north
I'll look for a landmark something to
point you in the right direction I'll
keep you posted over now what
well maybe we should see we could find
better as a group what is this logic of
do you know I'd actually know I'm a
badass I just remembered I'm a hardcore
go ahead ass and nothing is coming
what was that heard something I mean not
this I heard that sounded like steps
okay alright weird yeah Oh strange
Arthur okay hey bullet don't go too far
Oh let's stay close you guys stay close
bullet what's wrong what is wrong
anything wrong oh oh damn it it's
alright it's just a tree nothing wrong
with the tree the trees are fine good oh
hi hi how are you pretty good policy
just a tree no it's the base near a dead
white tree
[Applause]
that's enough Spencer keep us posted I
was over an hour oh wait wait so about
that tree um oh it's bleeding oh good
it's cut black goopy stuff I love black
goopy stuff hey you're a good boy or
good boy it's okay let me pet you in the
face of the tree right but there's
bleeding roots and you're a good dog
you're a good dog don't worry about that
you're a good dog don't worry about it
don't worry about a thing you'll be fine
hey what's that this looks nor was it
you was sand wouldn't it Sam get here
what is this what the hell is this yeah
found like a bunker actually you know if
anyone's ever done any construction work
out here reinforced concrete foundations
are trenches I know what I'm seeing
Lanie you know I bet I've read on Reddit
and I don't know how reliable it is but
I bet there were some pretty creepy
stories of people that work as a park
ranger or in the middle of the forest in
search and rescue parties what do you
what do you see boy what do you see yeah
yeah I know it's it's it's okay I'm
gonna go down and get this dark and
decrepit tunnel I've seen this from
farcry bunker bunker Oh weird I guess
we're not gonna find out I could try to
guess all right let's brute force this
bad boy Oh got it I found you out hey
god it's easy enough I mean when there's
only four and four like that it's not
that hard to
I know what it is okay they've been here
for so long that they can't even
remember what they once were barely
conscious barely alive someone could
just walk between them and they would
never notice they don't hear anything
they're nearly blind movement can draw
their attention if you get too close but
only light will agitate them like causes
them pain leave them alone and they
won't pay you any mind but make them
suffer and they won't stop until they
hunt you down I don't mind
I make them share my suffering okay
that's good
great oh I'm supposed to bring something
I probably wasn't supposed to brute
force my way in but it does look like
there's military ordnance in here which
is perfectly normal to have in the
middle of the woods oh hey how you doing
there
yeah bully you still there you good boy
you go boy you good boy you good boy
aren't you handsome you're so handsome
you so where Ansem you are oh boy
oh yeah a dumb boy stick close bullet
it's getting weird that's a little
better
just a little more ambience I think
what's happening is I'm in a little bit
of a nightmare world because there's no
reason why the videotape that I got
should work the way it did
bullet where'd you go bullet bullet get
out of there what are you doing well
what are you doing what is that Oh candy
wrapper really come on bullet you can do
better than that
Oh take a look go on see if you can find
something else
go on bullet yeah come on sniff sniff
the candy wrapper now show me okay come
on bullet well
bullet now what I'd expect in the middle
of the forest then again I wouldn't
expect me enforced concrete either yeah
neither would i okay bullet where are
you going
whoa where's bullet going did you find
oh there you go buddy oh this is much
better okay let's see
the breadcrumb Oh a weird wait is that
it's Peter I didn't see that Peter move
ballsy move is up because he dropped a
baseball Peter didn't run away he was
kidnapped I found a tape it shows the
man who did it
[Applause]
they make use appear there's no time
landing we have to find the kid he's in
serious danger you don't have much
choice
look I won't do anything stupid I'm just
gonna find him and wait for you to catch
up oh we're already doing stupid fellows
Oh Dharma
god damn it Ellis Ellis please well I'm
in obvious trenches I saw earlier come
on bullet let's check him out it was
also something about tree falling down
right here okay that's that's a
different truck okay so that's a
different truck so I got to get back to
the bunker wherever that was
oh it's real pleasant and I with no
flashlight oh and there is the shot of
Matthews oh hey bull hey chimera in this
weird world that we live in come sniff
this thing come on boy
Peters in danger and we're the only ones
who can help we're the only ones that
can help him for some reason
take me to it take me to take me to take
me third come on go go go go go like to
Lucas I don't know if it's like outlast
we're actually a batteries for this
thing that I could find replacements to
er if it's just gonna be like that
forever Oh God
can I get my flash I bet you I would
like my flashlight please thank you yes
that's much better
okay all right boy good thank you
bullet that very helpful you sure this
is the right way buddy oh hey wait this
is the truck you want any circles boy
wait
he'll pull it well where are we going Oh
bullet bullet why
what where are you buddy oh oh oh come
on boy don't make me chase you bullet
bullet bullet where are you
well then what is happening I don't like
it I'm hitting my head I'm too much
Brule
okay there's boy I see bullet I see
bullet I see both hey bullet hey how are
you doing hey what was that what did you
see well what do you see what do you see
bullet that what was one thing I didn't
see thing pay attention to bullets
behavior hears growling will alarm me of
danger lurking in the dark during if I
keep him close he'll help you locate
enemies but if left alone will become
vulnerable I won't let a thing happen a
bullet
I would dive in front of a truck for
bullet in a heartbeat what the hell was
that
oh good blue tape that's different
[Applause]
keeps them away keeps me safe need to
hold on to the light well what about
that note that I got that said I
shouldn't even bother him what about
that I don't know okay uh-oh well let's
stay close yeah I don't know if that is
okay
stay close bullets stick close bullet
okay that's fine whatever that was that
was fine those 100% fine everything
about that was just fine I love that
giant pulsating monsters in the woods
always good always oh it's good what is
the point what is the point
hey whoa whoa wait wait wait bullet
bullet bullet bullet bullet hey come
back yeah I know I know I know bullet
you're a good boy you're a good boy but
stay close to me I can't have you going
off oh boy where are you leaving me
bullet where you leading me Oh No stay
close why did we come here this is the
same tree or is this a different tree
this is the same tree how did we get
here but there was something over there
this doesn't make any sense
I swear this was the same place that
we've been but it's different and then
there was something over here and then
it wasn't there something else about
like a tree falling over here and if
there was can I make the tree not fall
here oh oh there she could hop it there
she goes way okay that's so cool that's
a fascinating mechanic what happens if I
watch the tape right here
Oh Oh it moved me oh I see it moved me
away that's awfully convenient and
that's an awful looking bridge oh boy Oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
I will answer that in the next episode
I have chapter for Wyatt chapter for her
excuse me how much is this game of my
playing I didn't think that much okay
but I'm gonna leave this here
it was cool I like this I like what it's
setting up I like what it's got going on
I like the mechanics of it so there's a
lot to like here but I will continue
this in the next episode so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you
[Music]